le dernier album de florent pagny sort
cette semaine savoir aimer le résultat
d'une rencontre d'une histoire d'amour
l'album de la maturité pour un chanteur
qui en dix ans de carrière a connu des
hauts et des bas michel vial benoît vers
en
une galerie de peinture par est a priori
un drôle d'endroit pour la promotion
d'un disque moins surprenant cependant
quand le chanteur s'appelle florent
pagny on connaît en effet depuis dix ans
son exubérance et son refus viscéral de
toutes les conventions mais à 36 ans
l'artiste a mûri et l'homme s'est assagi
depuis qu'il a rencontré sa moitié la
belle argentine a su sénat peintre
depuis dix ans
[Musique]
en
la jeune compagne et moi même
chacun dans sa discipline accompagnant
un album c'est dire que moi j'ai fait
les musiques j'ai chanté les chansons
plein de gens sont venus m'aider à faire
les musiques et puis je demander à ce
sénat si on pouvait accompagner
tout le livre est où le visuel tout ce
qui va avec les affiches ou ce qui va
accompagner ce disque avec ses peintures
jour après jour
c'est un album qui est plutôt liée à
l'amour mais à l'amour pas l'amour
déchirure passion comme ça à l'amour qui
avec sérénité avec maturité un amour
qu'on peut qui construit qui va vers le
haut comme ça sa voix
donner sans repenser de ne rien faire
qui apprend à apprendre à aimer
aimer sans attendre aimer à tout le
monde
on apprendra souris
entre la france et l'argentine florent
pagny n'a pas rogné ses racines de
paysans bourguignon et même s'il demeure
inclassable l'artiste a renoncé aux
frasques qui avait fini par masquer ses
incroyables qualités vocales d'où cet
album le cinquième qui devrait enfin le
réconcilier avec tous les publics
bien
échelle
son sort est sans problème
j'attends
[Musique]
bien
g
c'est une bande
je ne sais pas
[Musique]